Could this growing business survive an unexpected
tragedy? Ten Thirty One Productions started
off strong, but where is the company today?
On "Shark Tank," most pitches fall into familiar
categories, like household goods, technology,
childcare products, or food. It's relatively
rare for the sharks to consider pitches in the
entertainment realm. Yes, there have been a
few exceptions, like the inclusivity-oriented
comics company Black Sands Productions. There's
also Drive Suits' robotic car-themed strolling
performance venture. However, companies like Ten
Thirty One Productions are a relative anomaly.
The brainchild of entrepreneur Melissa Carbone,
Ten Thirty One Productions began as a company
that stages live horror-themed events. Their
most popular attraction is the Los Angeles
Haunted Hayride — a terrifying nighttime
trip through several scary tableaus set
up in the city's famed Griffith Park.
Carbone and her business partner and
ex-spouse Alyson Richards launched
Ten Thirty One Productions in 2009.
By the time of her "Shark Tank" pitch,
Ten Thirty One Productions' most lucrative
revenue stream came from the Haunted Hayride.
Each October, the Haunted Hayride was operational
for the 17 days leading up to Halloween. It
consistently sold out, adding up to about
$1.8 million in revenue in that period alone.
Carbone went into the tank to pitch her company
in October 2013, with her episode airing six days
before Halloween. She asked for $2 million
in exchange for a 10% equity stake in her
company. Kevin O'Leary and Robert Herjavek
didn't believe in her financial projections
for the following year, while Lori Greiner
didn't consider the investment worth her time,
so all three bowed out. Daymond John offered $2
million for 40%, but when Carbone countered with
the same dollar amount for 20%, Mark Cuban
swooped in and took the deal. And with that,
it was his biggest investment in
his first five seasons on the show.
"Everywhere I go there's zombies."
Ten Thirty One had big plans for expansion,
including a New York-based haunted hayride,
as well as a "Great Horror Campout" — an immersive
12-hour camp-a-thon filled with scares. Bigger
picture, Carbone wanted to have a Ten Thirty
One attraction in every major city in the U.S.
The first New York Haunted Hayride
was a success. In its first year,
it made 36% more than its Los Angeles
counterpart's second-year performance,
even if bad weather meant that it fell short of
its $5 million goal. This, along with Cuban's
investment, allowed Ten Thirty One to branch
out. As of May 2015, it offered two hayrides,
the camping attraction, a haunted cruise called
the "Ghost Ship," several Great Horror Movie Night
outings, and even a film production company that
aimed to make movies related to its attractions.
The popularity of Ten Thirty One Productions and
its numerous affiliated attractions has turned it
into one of the biggest "Shark Tank" success
stories out there. Of course, not every big
leap of faith that Mark Cuban or any of the other
Sharks have taken on an investment deal has turned
out so rosy, so it's worth looking closer at how
everything came together in this unique case.
As touched upon prior, Ten Thirty One Productions
was actually doing quite well even before it got
featured on "Shark Tank." Between having several
established brands and a solid stream of revenue,
the business was in no need of a savior. Melissa
Carbone told Dread Central in a 2017 interview,
"We were doing really well and I had little to
no interest in selling a piece of the company.
I recognized what the platform 'Shark
Tank' could provide so I reconsidered."
Indeed, arguably the greatest
effect of Cuban's involvement
with Ten Thirty One Productions is
how it allowed the venture to carry
out its pre-existing plans for expansion more
efficiently. In the interview, Carbone noted,
"The amount of time that opportunity
saves us on sourcing location, scouting,
and partnerships has been incredible.
It took a year to permit a location
for our first attraction and once we
became known and associated with Mark,
everyone in the country with a piece of land
or building to offer had us on speed dial."
It seems that Ten Thirty One Productions was bound
for success regardless of whether it
obtained a deal on "Shark Tank" or
not. Unfortunately, not everything was
smooth sailing for the growing company.
The New York Post reported that
back in 2016, one of the Haunted
Hayride set pieces — supposedly a
fog machine — fell on a customer,
leaving them severely injured. This led
to a lawsuit in 2018, and as a result,
Carbone sold Ten Thirty One to event company
Thirteenth Floor Entertainment Group. With that
said, she is still actively operating her
rides and events through the new company.